monsieur bergeron monsieur coderre
monsieur côté madame joly tout d'abord
merci d'être venu ici aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir accepté membres du conseil
d'administration membre de la chambre
membres de radio canada rdi distingués
invités mesdames et messieurs merci
d'être ici j'ai trois courtes minutes je
vais en 32 et demi d'abord je tiens à
souligner nous sommes à moins de deux
semaines de la date des élections
ce sont en en convient tous des
élections cruciales pour montréal et je
dirais d élection cruciale non seulement
pour montréal et pour le québec ce qui
se passe à montréal un impact sur
l'ensemble du québec c'est clair dans
notre esprit nous avons devant nous des
choix importants qu'à faire on a
beaucoup parlé d'intégrité et c'est
clair que ce que fait la commission
charbonneau ce que révèle upac est
nécessaire douloureux mais nécessaire
pour transformer la façon dont on fait
des choses à montréal mais on a un défi
historique a relevé et c'est celui de
notre torpeur économique nous avons de
la difficulté à créer des richesses à
montréal en 1991 au pib père capitaine
nous étions la 25e plus vils sur 25 en
amérique du nord non non on se parle on
est toujours prêts 25e ville sur 25 on
se le dit entre nous il n'y a pas de
visite c'est intime on doit faire mieux
sinon c'est un déclin relatif progressif
en amérique du nord sinon on verra des
boues tramway dans d'autres villes on
verra des autoroutes qui fonctionnent
avec des billettes des viaducs bien
conçu et des ponts signac est quand même
assez petit et avec tout ce qu'on a deux
spots présentement j'ai l'impression que
la chaleur monte tranquillement dans la
salle
et j'ai l'impression que pendant débat
la chaleur va monter encore un peu plus
avec la tension et puis des débords je
pense qu'on va voir vraiment un bel
échange alors je vous remercie d'être
d'être ici aujourd'hui de venir assister
au seul débat économique d'accord de la
campagne électorale à montréal il est
clair qu d'autres enjeux qui ont été
traités dans les débats et qui était
extrêmement important mais je pense que
le débat économique puis on a fait un
sondage de la semaine dernière à
radio-canada sondage crop radio canada
qui nous apprenait que
après la corruption la priorité des
montréalais c'est le développement
économique et la création d'emplois je
vous rappelle que le taux de chômage
dans l'agglomération de montréal et de
10 pour ça c'est le plus haut taux de
chômage au québec après la gaspésie les
îles de la madeleine alors on ne peut
pas ne pas parler d'économie ne pas
parler d'emploi vous parlez de ces
enjeux extrêmement important
c'est un donc un plaisir et un honneur
réel d'être associés à la chambre de
commerce du montréal métropolitain
d'associer rdi économie à cet événement
la rbi économie c'est une émission qui
est en nombre depuis septembre 2008
quand on dit septembre 2008 on se
rappelle du 15 septembre 2008 avec la
chute de lehman bros 2 je pense qu'à ce
moment là on a eu une très bonne idée de
lancer une émission d'économies ben ça
fait six ans qu'on est là parmi toutes
les grandes villes canadiennes et
québécoises mais les soucis plus élevé
que celui du reste la région
métropolitaine est encore plus important
plus élevé que celui du reste du québec
une anomalie unique dans tous les pays
industrialisés
pourquoi on essaie ainsi nous allons
traiter abondamment au sein du groupe de
travail que j'ai présidé avec toutes ces
guerres 2002 de cette question notre
rapport proposait 10 pistes de solution
mais depuis trois mois je me suis penché
de nouveau sur la question et j'en suis
venu à une conclusion fondamentale la
mauvaise gestion de la ville de montréal
est le principal facteur derrière la
mauvaise performance économique de
montréal les symptômes
si facilement je ne reviendrai pas non
plus sur nos infrastructures déficientes
les nids-de-poule et l'hybride eu que
deux qui entraînerait sauf avec une
question pourquoi ne lisons ton pas
entretenues voici quelques autres
symptômes qui nous laisse songeur onze
directeurs généraux à 12
est ce normal l'ordre du jour d'une
réunion typique du conseil de ville
quand 50 pages on trouve cela normal
montréal est non seulement devenue la
ville je crois parce qu'on en parle pas
il reflète les difficultés de montréal
de son économie est un appareil en
stratifié les rosés qui a perdu le sens
de ses coûts et de sa compétitivité
contrairement à la plupart des grandes
villes d'amérique du nord qui ont su se
transformer l'appareil administratif de
la ville de montréal est demeuré lourd
et accueille la restructuration qui a
amené des arrondissements ne fait qu
empirer une situation qui existait au
préalable quelle que soit la qualité des
gens qui avaient il ya déjà de très
bonne qualité à la ville
l'appareil administratif
particulièrement la ville sand est
désuet et dysfonctionnelle au fil des
ans depuis 106 l'eau se sont bâtis
freinant la collaboration et
déresponsabilisant les dirigeants la
culture organisationnelle est devenu
bureaucratique et a perdu de vue sa
finalité la provision de services
efficaces aux citoyens l'inefficacité le
59% les chantiers d heures d ordre du
jour de 50 pages l'état lamentable des
rues tous ces autres symptômes sont
devenus des choses normales la coalition
que je dirige propose une réforme
fondamentale
sur la vive la révolution tranquille de
montréal comme un préalable à toute
relance de son économie
nos plus importantes décisions seront
d'ailleurs pris dès le lendemain de
l'élection avec la formation du comité
exécutif les mandatent semmam et la
nomination d'un vice président aux
finances dans l'est du 1er 18 mois nous
entreprendrons une revue le monde autour
d'une table et trouvent des solutions à
tous les problèmes que l'on fera les
réformes en profondeur qui s'imposent
faire cette réforme demande d'être
capable de choisir les vraies priorités
et prendre les bonnes décisions qui
seront difficiles on ne brisera pas le
cas quand décisionnel et hans katif qui
freinent montréal depuis si longtemps
sans y mettre du courage monsieur engagé
à limiter les hausses de taxes foncières
à l'inflation j'ai confiance que je
pourrai le faire parce que derrière
cette promesse il y as substance de
réforme en profondeur et en priorité je
voudrais dire que toutes les économies
seront d'abord affecté à l'élimination
du déficit d'entretien des
infrastructures
au-delà de ces réformes il y aura une
politique économique comme maire je me
concentrer sur les avantages comparatifs
de montréal une ville de savoir est une
ville de créativité vous savez comme moi
que le focus le sens des priorités est
un attribut important du succès des
organisations
les maires ont tendance à s'éparpiller
dans 56 initiative vise de savoir et de
créativité dalli les priorités du maire
grappe technologique centre de recherche
attractions des créateurs des
professeurs des étudiants du monde
entier un brenton créativité promotion
de la culture et de l'entrepreneurship
milieu vivre conviviaux tolérance etc
c'est une économie dynamique par souci
par des citoyens et des investisseurs
qui ont non seulement confiance dans
leur ville mais qu'ils en sont six à
avoir l'expérience du pouvoir il faut
être en mesure aussi d'être proche des
gens il faut avoir cette proximité parce
que à chaque fois qu'on l'a on veut
faire des réformes à chaque fois qu'on
veut changer les choses tant sur le plan
structurel qu'au niveau du plan
économique on a besoin nécessairement de
la force de la population et c'est ce
que j'offre aujourd'hui je les ai dit à
plusieurs reprises au cours de la
campagne un des problème fondamental
c'est le manque de leadership le manque
de colonne vertébrale on manque de
leadership de vision on manque d'un
leadership de développement puis on
manque surtout d'un leadership
d'exécution on peut parler de structures
mais si on n'a pas ce leadership d'aller
de l'avant d'assumer pleinement les
décisions que l'on va prendre ça ne
fonctionnera pas il est temps que
montréal se comporte comme une métropole
il est temps que montréal arrête d'être
dans la salles d'attentes de jouer le
club-école à ottawa ou à québec qu'on
soit là pour quémander on doit exiger on
doit se respecter et on doit envoyer
comme message que nous ne sommes pas une
région comme les autres donc denis
coderre comme maire de montréal
s'assurera qu'on puisse pleinement
respecté ce que montréal est et doit
être une métropole le poumon économique
du québec la deuxième plus grande ville
au canada est une des plus belles villes
au monde donc nous allons non seulement
assumer notre leadership au niveau de
montréal un mécanisme de reddition de
compte pour la fonction publique et une
rotation des postes pour les
fonctionnaires et on pouvoir de décision
au niveau des achats nous allons
augmenter l'expertisé interne pour
revaloriser nos employés et diminuer le
recours à la sous-traitance nous allons
aussi évidemment faire du développement
économique une priorité à la ville à
l'heure actuelle dans l'organigramme
david le développement économique fait
partie du service de la mise en valeur
du territoire nous allons créer un
véritable service du développement
économique qui sera responsable de la
gestion des grands projets qui donnera
l'orientation politique de développement
local et en assurera la cohérence je
vous ai dit aussi depuis le début on a
certaines personnes qui essayaient de ce
concept là mais je veux faire de
montréal une ville intelligente smart
souris et des hommes portent une date
est plus grande
for technology
alors je veux grâce aux technologies de
l'information et des communications
faire de montréal une ville qui va aussi
répondre aux besoins des citoyens
assurer l'utilisation de la technologie
pour faciliter la culture
entrepreneuriale enlever toute cette
paperasse faire d'une réglementation
intelligente pour qu'à chaque fois qu'on
a à développer des dossiers avoir un
permis qu'on n'a pas attendre d
arrondissement non pour moi on ne peut
donner aux arrondissements ni au nombre
d'élus de toute façon en plus et 17
millions de dollars sur un budget de 4 -
9 milliards je pense qu'on a des choses
à faire mais il faut s'assurer que
beaucoup plus d'imputabilité et qui a un
meilleur contact avec les citoyens pour
que quand on prend des décisions avec la
traçabilité et la transparence
les gens voient que les élus font
effectivement leur travail au niveau de
la compagnie de compétitivité notre
mission pour les quatre prochaines
années sera de créer maintenir un
environnement idéal pour attirer les
entreprises donc dans un premier temps
il faut non seulement assurer d'appuyer
le développement du quartier de la santé
autour du chum et faire un héros un haut
lieu de savoir et de créativité dans le
domaine de la santé au canada travailler
avec la ganache technomontréal l'on veut
utiliser le savoir faire développé grâce
à la ville intelligente pour attirer
chez nous des entreprises pointe de
points créer un des grappes de design et
de culture pour valoriser ses industries
et en faire un levier de développement
économique appuyer des projets
favorisant la formule d' accélérateur
d'entreprises telles que le technoparc
en vue de multiplier la création
d'entreprise à vocation technologique et
afin de nous assurer d'avoir une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée disponibles optimisé
l'adéquation entre les programmes
collégiaux et universitaires les besoins
de formation des entreprises montréal ne
doit plus tolérer un taux de chômage de
10% par ailleurs on doit montréal doit
redevenir un lieu est fermé sans les
entrepreneurs veulent s'installer donc
on va assurer l'émergence d'une nouvelle
génération pme en uniformisant
simplifiant et accélérant les procédures
administratives
maintenant la création d'une entreprise
optimiser catastrophique la situation
économique de montréal n'est pas
reluisante quel que soit l'indicateur
montréal souffre trop souvent de la
comparaison avec les autres grandes
villes d'amérique du nord l'ensemble des
villes du québec et la soixantaine de
municipalités de banlieue qui entoure
l'île de montréal
deux raisons principales expliquent
cette situation
la première raison c'est l'exode année
après année de 22000 montréalais qui
quittent l'île de montréal pour les
vivent en banlieue
il y a un impact économique important
qui résulte de cet exode là à savoir le
transfert de 2.5 milliards de dollars
d'investissements du territoire de
montréal vers le territoire des
banlieues ce 2.5 milliards se sépare en
deux millions d'investissements dans le
secteur de la construction résidentielle
et 500 millions dans le secteur non
résidentiel
alors le meilleur exemple que vous
puissiez avoir de cet exode et de la
prospérité que s'entraîne pour les
municipalités qui entourent montréal au
détriment de montréal et le dix30 à
brossard traces faire aussi de 40 à 50
millions $ par année de revenus
municipaux des coffres de la ville de
marianne vers lykov de la soixantaine de
municipalités qui entoure l'île de
montréal bien sûr aussi création
d'emplois banlieue plutôt qu'à montréal
croissance supérieure du produit
intérieur brut avant lui plutôt qu'à
montréal c'était la première raison la
seconde raison est l'ailier d'accoucher
à la congestion et à la question plus
générale des transports la congestion
nous coûte aujourd'hui 2 8 milliards de
dollars par année
si on continue alors je propose un
horizon plus raccourci celui celui du
375e anniversaire de montréal l'année
2010 est en plus de ce que le
gouvernement va faire et que je viens de
vous décrire je propose que la ville de
montréal complète le dispositif de
rehausser le transport collectif par
l'implantation des 15 premiers
kilomètres du réseau tramway de montréal
encore là sur horizon 2017
si bien que sur cet horizon nous aurions
inciter nos transports collectifs
beaucoup plus performant il est bien
important de comprendre qu'aucun de ces
modes de transports collectifs ne se
pose aux autres c'est tous en même temps
l'objectif est de faire passer
l'achalandage annuel de la fcm de 400
millions aujourd'hui à 550 millions en
2020 pourquoi faut-il faire ça pour
améliorer la mobilité des montréalais
autrement que par la multiplication
infinie à l'infini du parc automobile et
pour rétablir la compétitivité du coeur
de montréal en tant que lieu de vie
la seconde solution j'ai parlé de
l'exode des familles la deuxième
solution c'est de retenir les familles à
montréal comment on fait ça bien sûr on
améliore le dispositif actuel de
rétention des familles essentiellement
fondée sur des subventions
on voit aussi à améliorer la qualité de
vie des quartiers comme nous l'avons
fait et j'en suis très fier dans le
plateau mont royal puisque qualité de
vie des quartiers création d'emplois
rétention des entreprises tout ça va ça
la preuve en est un que nous accueille
deux cent mille habitants et j'ajouterai
une note particulière pour le centre
ville de montréal il nous faut attirer
75000 habitants de plus au centre ville
de montréal
là cet objectif vous paraît trop
ambitieux comparez le à ce qui a été
réussi à vancouver dans cette matière en
1985 quand gordon campbell est devenu
maire de vancouver il y avait quarante
deux mille habitants ou centre ville de
vancouver au dernier recensement de 2011
102 mille habitants il n'y a plus un
seul terrain vague dans tout le centre
ville de vancouver il n'y a plus un seul
stationnement de surface dans tout le
centre ville de vancouver la rive
puisque s'agissant d'une péninsule elle
est bordée d'eau de part et d'autre a
été entièrement aménagé un espace de
calais un espace accessible au public et
aménagé de très grande qualité alors
voilà ce qu'il nous faut faire au centre
ville si on réussit ses soixante-quinze
mille habitants ça veut dire aussi
mécaniquement un million de pieds carrés
d'espacé commercial supplémentaire
au centre-ville et
vraisemblablement aussi un million de
pieds carrés d'espacés à bureaux
supplémentaires alors c'est pas
compliqué je veux que nous fassions du
centre-ville de montréal le plus beaux
centres villes des amériques on est
présentement en concurrence avec new
york avec san francisco et avec
vancouver il n'y a que 4 centre ville
vivant plurifonctionnel où il ya une
activité culturelle très forte où il ya
des habitants des quatre heures par jour
nous sommes de ces quatre de ses quatre
centres viennent en mairie jean à
propulsion nous au premier rang
pour fait merci
quatrième candidate mélanie joly le vrai
changement pour montréal groupe mélanie
joly
bonjour à toutes et à tous je souhaite
d'abord remercié la chambre de commerce
du montréal métropolitain pour cette
invitation à vous présenter la vision de
mon équipe et moi pour un montréal qui
offre la meilleure qualité de vie au
monde si 2021 cet objectif n'est pas
anodin comme vous le savez mieux que
quiconque dans ce monde constamment en
mouvement les sièges sociaux
s'établissent là où le talent se
trouvent et les jeunes talents
s'établissent là où ils peuvent jouir de
la meilleure qualité de vie c'est à ce
projet de transformation de montréal que
je vous confie donc à compter du 4
novembre prochain comme partenaire pour
une ville de classe mondiale notre
propre notre programme comprend dix
actions dont la réalisation nous
permettra de nous rapprocher de notre
objectif lequel guidera l'ensemble des
gestes concrets posés par mon
administration mais je n'y arriverais
pas seul en plus de la des montréalais
incluant vous membres de sa communauté
d'affaires j'entends m'entourer de
personnes d'expérience ainsi dans les
100 premiers jours de mon mandat mon
administration procédera à la nomination
de trois postes clés un chef du
développement économique un chef du
numérique et le directeur général d'air
froid montréal
ces personnes soit pour y arriver ceux
ci commencera par la nomination d'un
directeur du numérique
appuyé par une équipe de crack de
l'informatique des gi une geek squad qui
travaillera avec les différents services
municipaux de la ville sainte et des
arrondissements pour qu'il rende
accessible au public toutes les données
colligées par l'administration
municipale une telle transparence aura
une incidence directe sur l'imputabilité
des élus bien entendu mais également sur
l'appareil municipal puisque les
citoyens auront la chance d'assurer le
suivi en temps réel de la gestion des
fonds publics
l'ouverture complète des données de la
ville permettra de plus aux
entrepreneurs dans le numérique de créer
des applications qui utilisent nos
données améliorant la gestion des
services et la qualité des services aux
citoyens à titre de futur maire est de
montréal je m'engage d'ailleurs à donner
personnellement mon compte-rendu sur les
dix actions que j'ai proposé durant la
campagne électorale et ce sur une base
mensuelle j'expliquerai où nous en
sommes ce qui nous reste à accomplir et
ceux qui nous bloque si le cas échéant
troisième axe les infrastructures en
plus de mettre l'accent en plus de
mettre de côté la règle du plus bas
soumissionnaire et de la remplacer par
un mode d'octroi de contrats
d'infrastructure basée sur la qualité
mon administration s'attaquera de front
au problème de la planification et de la
coordination des travaux
d'infrastructures en effet tant il est
anormal que dans une ville comme
montréal seulement 40% des travaux
planifiés dans une année se réalise non
pas faute de budget ce d'obtention selon
des étapes et des règles qui sont
claires et des avec des objets des
critères objectifs et publics
les demandes de permis seront ainsi
soumises à un calendrier décisionnel
cours et contraignant pour
l'administration dont les échéances se
comptera en semaines plutôt qu'en mois
selon les nouvelles règles que mon
administration mettre en place les
décideurs auront désormais l'obligation
de motiver par écrit les décisions et
celles ci seront rendus publics selon
nos politiques de données ouvertes de
plus comme mairesse j'entends simplifier
la réglementation
pour ce faire nous mettrons sur pied un
comité composé de gens d'affaires comme
vous et de fonctionnaires présidée par
le chef du développement économique
ce comité passera en revue l'ensemble de
la réglementation de la ville et des
arrondissements dans le but de proposer
des modifications visant à éliminer les
contraintes excessives et les autres
freins au développement économique de
montréal par ailleurs le chef du
développement économique de montréal
prendra la tête de la division du
développement économique qui sera
réorganisé afin de lui permettre de
s'acquitter d'un maintenant d'un mandat
étendu la division agira ainsi est
dorénavant à titre de guichet unique
pour l'accès aux différents programmes
et accompagnera les autres preneur dans
leur processus d'obtention de permis
enfin en menant à bien nos réformes et
en diversion diversifiant par donc les
sources de revenus de la ville ce qui
nous permettra de réduire la dépendance
de montréal aux taxes frontières nous
comptons être en mesure au terme d'un
premier mandat de diminuer le fardeau
fiscal des montréalais en effet ni pas
normal
alors voilà pour la partie présentation
des différents candidats il est presque
18 heures et nous reste quelques minutes
pour installer les candidats mettent les
microphones donc tous les tests
techniques vous restez là vous bougez
pas vous sortez pas on commence les
tests techniques ça dure à peu près dix
minutes je dois de vous parler et à 18
heures on commence le débat
et on invite tout de suite les candidats
les quatre candidats à monter sur scène
s'il vous plaît immédiatement pour vous
installer
alors
ce que tu devais compter sur moi compter
sur moi on a fait des débats et
d'économie ensemble qui jeu
oui mais c'est sûr que je ne peux pas
vous obstinez 3 contre 1 ou je ne sais
trop mais c'est sûr vous allez
autres concerts on va le voir comment ça
va et après ça on avisera
oui oui
clément dans un groupe i
c'est sur twitter doit si
ça va
on dit qu'on
allait des containers qui parle j'ai
regardé l'heure joyeuse des cantines
ouais c'est bon mais de façon ça va
bouger leur quand je parle pour mon 45
secondes par exemple max et quelle
caméra c'est celle là c'est la hague est
mort c'est toujours là
1 2 3 4 5 6
sur grapotte
sa voix
parfait merci
germain
m
mesdames
on commence dans trois minutes est ce
que tout le monde va bien oui michel un
problème
hubert hubert nous suit par le web de
partout et heures par nos discussions en
direct à radio canada.ca barre oblique
des beaux arts dits sur internet
il est en moi hubert aussi hubert
lacroix on est on est on est on fait
corps ensemble ici hubert lacroix
alors
en deux minutes bonsoir aux quatre
candidats commencer dans deux minutes
j'espère que la première partie vous
servez vous réchauffer en quelque sorte
d'ange est prêt la
répression un
excellent alors la façon que ça va se
passer je vais poser quelques questions
durant la soirée durant le débat d'une
heure et puis les candidats vont
répondre va y avoir des échanges vous
avez droit d'un petit peu réagir mais
pas trop en même temps parce que pas
question de se mettre à applaudir lors
quand votre candidat fin mon cou c'est
quand même assez serré comme débat ça
dure 58 minutes donc on respecte ça
c'est sûr que s'il ya quelqu'un qui fait
ça brille bonne blague de le droit de
rire ou si j'en fais une 9e bonsoir
bienvenue à ce débat le ce débat
économique de la campagne électorale à
montréal nous sommes en direct du palais
des congrès à montréal avec plein de
gens ici c'est l'émission rdi économie
mais en une heure et dans une nouvelle
formule complètement c'est un débat avec
les candidats les principaux candidats à
la mairie présenté en collaboration avec
la chambre de commerce du montréal
métropolitain
merci d'être avec nous ce soir on a
quatre candidats quatre thèmes quatre
débats les candidats sont mélanie joly
denis coderre marcel côté richard
bergeron bonsoir à vous quatre ans soit
merci beaucoup d'être là voici le
fonctionnement de nos débats je vais
poser une question à un candidat en
particulier qui aura 45 secondes pour
répondre et ensuite on ouvre le débat à
quatre et ensuite il y aura une question
du public qui viendra de maxime bertrand
et on va encore ouvrir le débat à quatre
candidat qui va répondre à la question
de relance de maxime est donc le débat
ensuite à 4 et bien sûr moi je peux
poser des questions je pose des
questions je vous demande des précisions
je vous demande d'être clair je m'assure
que chaque personne puisse parler et si
vous parlez en même temps je peux me
fâcher mais ça n'arrivera pas je suis
corpiq les collaborer pleinement et à la
maison radio canada.ca barres obliques
débat et redit si vous voulez participer
à cet échange poser des questions
interagir n'hésitez pas dans les
sondages et surtout dans le sondage de
la semaine dernière radio canada on a vu
que les montréalais l'une de leurs
priorités une des grands sorte que
montréal est l'endroit au québec où il
ya le plus de chômage après la gaspésie
les îles de la madeleine il est clair
qu'on peut pas vous demander de créer
une entreprise et de créer d'emplois
mais ce que vous avez un objectif
ambitieux réaliste chiffrés en termes de
création d'emplois et de réduction du
taux de chômage ce qu elle faisait 45
secondes merci beaucoup monsieur fillion
d'hitler que la première chose qu'on a
besoin c'est d'un c'est d'un chef de
file si vous voulez que les choses
fonctionnent si on veut créer
l'environnement propice à
l'investissement si on veut créer de
l'emploi vous avez besoin d'un leader
alors le maire doit être leader mais la
première chose qui doit faire c'est de
faire de l'ordre dans sa propre maison
alors si un problème de service si un
problème de livraison de permis si vous
avez une réalité d'infrastructures on a
besoin dès les premiers jours avec
l'expérience que j'ai la sensibilité du
terrain j'ai l'expérience du pouvoir
parce que j'ai déjà été ministre et j'ai
eu des règles et des dossiers on est en
mesure de régler dès le premier jour
d'un comité exécutif parce que moi j'ai
une équipe deuxièmement faire en sorte
qu'on peut savoir rapidement le prochain
budget changer le pays et je veux
travailler avec les autres pour arriver
à trouver les solutions débat est ouvert
si bergeron c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites monsieur coderre mais vous ne
tenez pas compte du fait qu'à chaque
année il y avait 2000 montréalais qui
quittent moyens pour la banlieue et il
se crée énormément d'emplois en banlieue
la preuve ces dix dernières années au
moins 10 millions de pieds carrés
d'espacé commercial ont ouvert en
banlieue compte appropriées sur une rue
commerciale qui vont plutôt mal non
celle qui veut que vous avez c'est que
vous êtes colère toujours en termes
d'exode et quand on regarde en absolu le
1.6 % d'augmentation à chacun négocie
260000 montréalais ces douze dernières
années aux nets ont quitté montréal pour
la banlieue il faut pas se surprendre
que les emplois dans les services on
parle de dizaines de milliers de
centaines de milliers d'emplois a été
créé en banlieue et non pas montréal et
à terme le secteur manufacturier lui
aussi se déplace vers la bonne moi je
veux juste vous rappeler un chiffre là
je vous demande de chiffrer clairement
vos objectifs en termes d'emploi et de
chômage s'y lie à augmentation des
démographes ya mon rêve parce que plus
d'immigrants à montréal présentement les
montréal perd au niveau de la province
qui au niveau des autres régions qu'on
se connaît on peut réduire sa propre
aller en deçà de 7 % mais le problème
qu'on a présentement qu'il faut
comprendre comment fonctionne la réalité
montréalaise ce que vous avez beaucoup
de nouveaux arrivants qui ont des
diplômes et sont pas reconnus donc c'est
sûr que la première chose on doit
reconnaître les diplômes mais faut
arrêter de travailler aussi en vase clos
on n'est pas seulement le maire de
montréal je vais devenir le président de
la cmm donc il faut à au thème du
rayonnement toute politique doit se
faire de façon régionales il ya déjà des
le quartier de l'innovation le quartier
de la santé on est on est dessus pas à
qualifier on à la réalité universitaire
on est une ville de savoir arrêtons
d'être misérabiliste un peu mais mettons
les bonnes personnes aux bonnes places
la cmm c'est la communauté
métropolitaine la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal la grande
région de montréal madame joly vous
savez c'est pas une question d
misérabiliste ou non c'est une question
me dire dans la mesure où on a aussi eu
l'idée force incroyable à montréal mais
il faut créer les l'environnement
d'investissement qui est sain et pour ce
faire faut prendre des mesures concrètes
faut pas juste dénoncent-ils du
transport collectif qui veut pouvoir
unir l'est et l'ouest montréal dans
notre plateforme on est arrivé avec une
action très concrète de 130 km2 système
rapide par bus pour justement faciliter
la mobilité à travers montréal et deux
se fait attirer des investissements et
donc en faisant sortir justement
d'offrir du transport en commun aux gens
de rivière des prairies lasalle lachine
pierrefonds et puis ce que ce soit
facile pour ses personnels de se rendre
au centre de montréal mais que les gens
de rosemont petite patrie
plateau-mont-royal plus facilement se
rendre à l'épaule d'emplois je pense
notamment à ceux de saint laurent ou
bien à anjou le débat est ouvert ou
est-ce qu'on a perdu des emplois à
montréal manufacturés cédant laisse y
actuellement des très grands terrains
industriels qui peuvent être peu
développée il ya un projet pour
compléter voire l'assomption ya un
projet pour faire une nouvelle ouverture
sur le port de montréal il faut
encourager ses projets lors qu'il faut
encourager les sélects locales et y en a
trois dans l'ès les quoi le ksc
d'actrice les centres de développement
économique économique le coup la voie là
et il faut les encourager à développer
d'entrepreneurship et sauf dans les en
laisse une vocation manufacturière le
manufacturier revient en amérique il
faut aller le capturer lamballerie son
côté monsieur bergeron et la mégane
montréal premièrement il faut
diversifier l'économie on a eu des
problèmes lorsque par exemple on a fermé
la raffinerie shell où il ya plus
justement leadership notamment de la
ville qui aurait dû faire quelque chose
en ce sens mais clairement vous avez il
faut diversifier l'économie on avait
déjà on est déjà des tables de
concertation il ya la réalité du
pipeline l'inversement du pipeline
numéro 9 sur sa voie c'est en
partenariat avec les autres ordres de
gouvernement pour nous assurer qu'on
puisse travailler à représenter
le gouvernement du québec essaie de
pousser la fabrication 20h02 de voitures
électriques je peux selectric au québec
c'est toujours ce qui va prendre du
temps si on veut régler les problèmes de
l'est il faut pas dans des filières qui
vont se développer beaucoup plus
rapidement on peut prendre la filière
pétrochimique en allant vers la chimie
verte avec le pipeline de
bridge et il ya des possibilités aussi
de raviver du manufacturier
conventionnelle sincèrement penser qu'on
va fabriquer mais nous deux mais le trou
et le bus électriques en tous genres qui
dit non à l'aéronautique homme innocent
canard jamais je l'entends il y avait
déjà un usine qui produisait des avions
la borne n'a pas encore fait renvoyer un
bus électrique courir vers feuillette
mais c'est abi qui s'est pas le maire de
montréal qui fait du développement
économique il ya une village et non ils
créent l'environnement sain pour que les
entrepreneurs puissent arriver et
investi un moral est si important à
comprendre la différence et nous
justement on veut s'assurer pour qui est
du développement économique de clarifier
les processus d'approbation de s'assurer
qu'il ya des critères clairs que non on
est des délais d'approbation proclame
compris je comprends que madame joly au
pas d'expérience non la réalité de la
ville c'est que quand on travaille en
isolement économique
entre autres
on est économique que ce soit en
politique municipale que ce soit en
politique fédérale ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir un catalyseur c'est
d'avoir quelqu'un qui va être un
promoteur on est une métropole on a un
rôle à jouer dans le rayonnement est en
nettement 103 élus au total la question
est à richard bergeron d'abord il ya
beaucoup de citoyens des gens d'affaires
également qu'ils trouvent que la
structure administrative actuelle est
trop lourde qu'on est sûr gouverner en
même temps est ce qu on veut recommencer
à revoir la structure donc la question
c'est dans la structure actuelle est ce
que montréal vous permet d'aller de
l'avant avec vos ambitions dans la
structure actuelle vous avez 45 secondes
super g je commencerai par précisé que
la structure actuelle nous a été imposée
par un gouvernement québec en fait enfin
en vertu de ses objectifs politiques à
lui comme le chambardement de 2001 nous
avait été imposée aussi par québec en
vertu des objectifs poursuivis par le
gouvernement qui est en place à ce
moment là alors moi je propose que nous
organisions une grande réflexion et
grand débat sur entre montréalais sur le
système de gouvernance que nous
souhaitons alors bien sûr c'est
compliqué une ville 19 arrondissements
mais je fais remarquer que ceux qui
parlaient de réduire le nombre d'élus
réduire le nombre d'arrondissements il y
a deux ans maintenant s'appuie sur cette
caractéristique de montréal pour prendre
le pouvoir prétendre tenté de prendre le
pouvoir à montréal bien sûr je fais
référence à mes deux collègues de ma
droite le débat est ouvert hier si messi
d'argent moi je pense que le problème
présentement on a c'est gaspiller de
salive sur la centralisation versus
cette décentralisation
il est temps qu'on passe à l'action
soyons soyons honnêtes le c 17 millions
de dollars sur quatre points 9 milliards
de budget total moi je pense qu'on doit
faire c'est très clairement avoir
beaucoup plus de cohérence
professionnaliser davantage la fonction
publique s'assurer que l'on plaint
budgétaire la ville de montréal ya des
problèmes pour sté l'étude des problèmes
budgétaires beaucoup plus criant que
submergeront à la faveur du débat que je
propose je pressens que nous allons nous
réconcilier avec notre modèle de
gouvernance pour ce qui concerne les
tâches politiques je ne m'attends pas à
ce qu'il ya réduction significative du
nombre d'élus non plus que donc du
nombre d'arrondissements mais aussi à la
faveur de ce débat là il ya énormément à
faire un étage en dessous du politique
qui est laitages administratif et là il
ya beaucoup de regret noté est ce qu'on
a besoin de 20 directeur des sports et
loisirs à montréal 19 dans les 19
arrondissements plus à la ville sans je
soupçonne que la réponse des montréalais
va être non ils vont demander plus de
régionalisation comme je le suis je suis
d'accord avec monsieur bergeron au
niveau de la rationalisation que des
réformes importantes à faire au sein
d'arkema les organigrammes puis
l'organisation mais aussi je voudrais
pas que ce soit au détriment de comment
je fais de la motivation de notre
fonction publique on a beaucoup
d'expertisé à montréal on a quand même
une fonction de public de qualité et moi
ce que je veux faire c'est que je veux
investir dans la fonction publique de
montréal faire en sorte comme dans les
années 60 où les corps public était
capable d'attirer les meilleurs talents
qu'on puisse avoir une fonction publique
qui nous rend fiers que les gens sont
fiers de travailler pour montréal et en
même temps une fonction publique qui
représente les manques allez vous
ajouter des postes dans la fonction
publique ou en supprimer moi ce que je
veux faire en fait c'est quand on veut
gagner on va faire des gains en
efficacité étant donné que max avoir
accès à toute l'information que la ville
détient on va pouvoir voir qu'est ce qui
achoppe alain terme je peut il donc dans
les services ans à partir à l'assaut au
niveau à la quatrième année de notes
mans abondamment par les candidats a
même proposé un grand débat sur la
question mais lorsqu'il s'agit de
gouvernance vous savez il s'agit aussi
de relations de la métropole avec le
gouvernement du québec alors faut-il
revoir ses rapports faute il renégocie
impact fiscal par exemple alors monsieur
vandemeulebroucke demande ce qu'il faut
faire afin que québec devienne un
partenaire économique de montréal et non
un adversaire
questions questions très clair qu'on
pose d'abord à marcel côté 45 secondes
tous les candidats à la mairie depuis 20
ans montréal on réponde à ce que si on
l'observé fr en fait ça prend une
stratégie pour renforcer
voire de négociation de montréal face à
québec il faut s'allier objectivement et
solidement avec la banlieue avec la
banlieue montréalaise on représente 50 %
de la population du québec près de 60%
du pib le premier étape faire délier
plus étroits avec la banlieue dans un
deuxième temps c'est sûr qu'on doit
refuser de pacte fiscal mais il est en
révision actuellement et là toutes les
municipalités du québec demande pas que
jusqu'à il faut que québec reconnaissent
dans ce pacte fiscal là la situation
particulière de montréal qui est
thermalisme qui fait lui-même beaucoup
de services qui ailleurs sont fournies
par les banques je suis d'accord avec le
constat de monsieur côté ceci dit ce
pour ça qu'on arrive avec toi 1% de la
tvq générés sont un territoire et
pourquoi en propose parce que un c'est
important comme en rien les statuts
particuliers d'un point de vue fiscal
mais au-delà de ça on a une opportunité
de négocie présentement au moment même
où toutes les municipalités au québec
arrive et négocier à nouveau assumer
pleinement deuxièmement si on n'est pas
capable de jouer notre rôle sur le plan
régional on sera pas capable justement
d'être incontournable au niveau de
québec donc il faut aussi penser que
c'est un gouvernement minoritaire en
pensant justement c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire si on connaît la fonction
publique québécoise si on connaît le jeu
politique si on est capable de se lever
solidairement pour la métropole on est
capable de prendre notre place mais faut
commencer par du courant est important
ce que vous dites parce que le maire de
montréal devient aussi le président de
la communauté métropolitaine de montréal
82 maires cinq régions administratives
50 % de l'économie du québec monsieur
pour quelques la sant 5 avec monsieur
bergeron parce que projet montréal ne
crois pas beaucoup à la communauté
métropolitaine moi je crois qu on doit
au contraire investir s'associer fou
trouver une façon s'associer fermement
avec la région métropolitaine on a
beaucoup d'intérêts communs et je vois
pas pourquoi on chicaneries on peut se
liguer ici on se met ensemble on peut
avoir quelque chose de québec vous avez
évité que fait le maire de montréal est
élu par les montréalais pour défendre
les montréalais et non pas pour défendre
simultanément les raisons 2 mascouche de
sainte-julie où je me suis trop doux
alors il faut que les montréalais un
défend et un défenseur par ailleurs
j'insiste pour dire que je n'appartiens
à aucune formation politique à québec ou
à ottawa je ne serais pas obligé de
suivre les lignes souhaité par ma
famille politique à québec ou à ottawa
alors pour une fois avec moi les
montréalais auront un ardent défenseur
de leur intérêt quand on veut faire du
métro du tramway du srd et des voies
réservées on passe à travers des
arrondissements on passe à travers des
municipalités également comment on fait
pour gérer sans sens où la question de
la sécurité une équipe on doit avoir une
forêt bien et si on l'a pas ça marche
pas suffi troisième thème monsieur
bergeron vous allez parler là pour
prochain thème d'accord alors troisième
thème budget taxation
on paye plus qu'on ne croit plus de
services oui je paye beaucoup de taxes
mais je pense que c'est pour le bien de
balles à menzel vraiment faire un examen
de conscience sur les sorties d'argent
commune désire s'en faire je pense pas
qu'on a besoin de payer plus je pense
que si l'argent est mieux géré il y
aurait assez déjà pour faire ses grands
projets quand on voit tous les scandales
de collusion qui tu sors on voit bien
qu'on ne peut pas notre argent je
regarde l'état des routes l'état des
trottoirs c'était plus en terme de
fermer les robinets on n'aura pas le
choix faut qu'ils en grèce inquiète pas
sinon on est perdu d'avancé
parlons de lavabos puisqu'il faut fermer
le robinet qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans il
ya un budget de 4 milliards 900 millions
de dollars pour la ville de montréal les
deux tiers de sa vient de la taxation 67
% des revenus la hausse prévue des taxes
et de 2 2% la première question est à
mélanie joly vous avez un peu répondu à
cette question donc je vais là précisé
si vous permettez parce que les taxes
occupe déjà une place importante dans
l'assiette fiscale de montréal que ces
taxes sont déjà en augmentation est ce
qu'il ya d'autres moyens pour la ville
de ce financier donnez-nous une solution
qui peut-être même deux solutions parce
que vous l'avez donné votre première
solution tantôt pour que montréal ait
plus de moyens financiers vous avez 45
secondes enfin nous on est arrivé avec
un plan match dans les trente mille
familles à montréal le fait d'un et
30000 famille amour hassam n 31 millions
meilleure situation financière donc
montréal - d'argent supplémentaire du
gouvernement deux points c'est tout
cramé on a besoin pour les grands
événements transport sans plus la
première étape c'est s'assurer qu'on
sache vraiment ce qui se passe c'est
qu'on a besoin d'une révision des
programmes avant de commencer à demander
des revenus supplémentaires parce que
tout le monde est choqué tout le monde
est tanné de payer faut voir comment
comment vont les dépenses donc c'est
pour ça que sur le plan structurel je
proposais l'inspecteur général
concernant toute la politique d'achat
mais ce qui est aussi important c'est de
voir comment ça se fait que l'otan de
table et et qui sont payés à rien faire
à montréal commentera les dédoublements
dans les deux personnages parlent de
personnes comment ça se fait qu'il ya
autant de dédoublement ce sens le dont
la première étape vu que j'ai une équipe
mois puis qu'on va avoir des gens à un
comité exécutif qui vont être prêts à
travailler cette faire une révision des
programmes dans les prochains dans les
prochaines semaines par la crue on
arrête on peut donner à tous toutes les
policiers y a pas un politicien vous dit
que votre vetex pour tailler élèves de
temps en temps présélection alors une
question crédibilité publication signale
qu on avr moi je peux vous dire que j'ai
mille articles numéro 1 2 3 4 5 6 dans
mon programme là c'est une meilleure
gestion de la ville de montréal qui est
très mal géré et je le répète et c'est
par le contrôle des dépenses le contrôle
beaucoup plus serré des dépenses la
réforme la façon dont les faits les
décisions dépenses se font à la ville de
montréal qu'on veut dégager un peu de
marge de manoeuvre pour gérer montréal
comme une entreprise l'homme de grandeur
et de plus éric comme des avec des
comptes au pouvoir avec un directeur
financier par exemple qu'adulte la
gueule du tonus l'ordre de grandeur des
gains qu'on peut faire avec ce que
monsieur côté ce nom mais je pars côté
passé 50 à 100 millions ça alors c'est
important qu'on fasse mais bon on
s'assoit qu'on est
remboursé le trop rapide a marqué dans
une amnistie comme ça ça veut dire qu en
a qui vont s'en trouver en quelques mois
alors je pense qu'avant tout c'est la
première étape le réalistement faut être
pragmatique c'est de voir qu'est ce
qu'on a dans notre propre cour qu'est ce
qu'on est capable de sauver tout de
suite là ils veulent les gens veulent
des réponses immédiates mathieu bergeron
je suis au regret de dire madame joly
quelle défense une porte ouverte cette
négociation entre le grondement du
québec l'industrie de la construction
l'instru 'j'ai du génie conseil elle est
en cours et parce que j'ai lu dans le
devoir je vous ai je vous apprends alors
qu'elle est en et moi on doit avoir un
très grand père est un très grand
intérêt à sauver notre industrie de la
construction qui est excellent et notre
industrie de génie-conseil qui est
excellente aussi excellent questions du
public on retrouve tout de suite maxime
bertrand dans la salle
d'écouté c'est presque une question
viscéral madame joly disait on est tanné
que les mots relève pétantes assez bien
croyez moi elle n'est pas la seule
bennoo mais elle nous a écrit il veut
savoir ce que chaque candidat fera au
cours des prochaines années afin de
réduire le budget de fonctionnement de
la ville de montréal et conséquemment
les taxes foncières merci maxime c'est
intéressant parce qu'il ya des
compressions dans plusieurs appareils
gouvernementaux
alors il ya une question sur le budget
de fonctionnement puis à une question
sur les taxes et l'on veut que vous
soyez précis parce qu'on veut sortir ce
soir c'est clair qu'on sache si vous
augmentez de combien les taxes denis
coderre d'abord 45 secondes d'écouté
premièrement un pour moi ce qui est
clair c'est qu'on peut pas aller au delà
du taux de l'inflation on a un travail à
faire nous mêmes la don pour les quatre
prochaines années l'eau c'est pour plus
que le taux d'inflation ce qu'on doit
faire cependant c'est de faire avec la
révision des programmes de voir comment
l'argent comment l'argent dépensé 6
prend des taxes ont augmenté de la
station tout les économies que nous
allons réaliser et nous aurons réalisé
beaucoup validant réfection des rues
dans réfection des a que deux le métro à
sedan fait dans toutes les dépenses
d'entretien qu'on néglige depuis au
moins dix quinze ans et qui nous donne
la situation que tout le monde déplore à
montréal c'est à dire des rues des
trottoirs qui sont dans des
établissements
pour notre argent dont la transe la
maladie la traçabilité des décisions le
fait d'avoir une ville intelligente
quand on démontre aux gens changent et
des fonds consolidé pour des fonds
dédiés quand les gens voient comment
l'argent dépensé ils vont devenir des
pleins partenaires ils vont faire partie
de la solution alors bien sûr moi aussi
je m'engage à ne pas hausser les taxes
plus que l'inflation se fait quand même
dix ans que les fonds du projet montréal
alors j'ai un peu d'avancé sur vous je
sais que c'est sage de l'annoncer comme
ça j'ai dit tantôt j'ai établi dans tous
les ordres de grandeur la réforme
administrative maximum 100 millions par
année trouvés obligés l'opération les la
fin de la collusion de la corruption 100
millions d'un budget d'investissement
c'est ça les bonzes ordre de grandeur
est peut être à lui seul 14 non mais y
est financé sur 30 ans monsieur côté
quand même j'ai financé est un mode de
transport coûteux comparativement notre
juge les a jugés 'sans dans la salle et
chez vous le ski va apparaître dans le
budget d'opération de la ville sur la
période 2014-2017 ses 75 millions par le
biais du service de la dette vous
devriez savoir ça monsieur côté on paie
louer est un système de transport après
on finance sur 30 ans à chaud qui se
répercute dans le budget d'opération par
le biais du service de la dette et à
hauteur de 75 millions des régimes de
retraite il le faut
tout le monde est d'accord
que sonia il faut faire en sorte que
montréal comme ville et un pouvoir de
négociation a un pouvoir de la carte
parce que dans la ville de montréal ne
te voit ce pouvoir là et on veut
s'assurer que dans un contexte de
cotisations qu'il ya une parité entre
les employeurs et la ville
et ses discours se sont montrés ouverts
à la parité est ce que vient dire madame
joly la lys et du corps sont d'accord
cette entraide sauf un tracking mars en
grève sans perturbation dans la région
les riches et les cols bleus pour le
déficit actuariel vers 14h45 et thème
numéro quatre thèmes numéro 4
environnement d'affaires et promotion de
montréal
les pme sont très importante dans
l'économie canadienne donc il faudrait
faudrait probablement promouvoir sa
beaucoup plus forts flinck avec les
entreprises pour les garder à montréal
et n'avoir plus et créer de l'emploi
faut que les gens travaillent il
faudrait davantage
planifier les travaux des gens
viendraient plus dans le centre ville si
c'était plus facile de circuler donner
plus d'importance à leur public et le
rayonnement de montréal à
l'international je pense que la
volatilité politique ce n'est pas très
attirant pour pour les compagnies bon
alors c'est très intéressant les gens
d'affaires dit souvent que c'est
compliqué trouver des permis entre les
arrondissements qui la ville centre que
les taxes commerciales sont élevées pour
les entreprises que montréal ait des
choses des gens d'affaires dont je suis
d'accord avec mon collègue côté là
dessus et la première chose qu'il faut
dont il faut s'assurer je parle aux
électeurs montréalais assurez vous de ne
pas remettre les mêmes personnes le même
système les mêmes réseaux d'argent au
pouvoir si vous voulez pas que sarnez
sous une autre forme ensuite on
s'occupera de l'environnement d'accueil
que doit être le ville de montréal pour
les entreprises tout particulièrement
celle de la nouvelle économie qui sont
très mobiles à l'échelle internationale
là où il faut faire attention c'est de
dire que montréal n'est pas riche mont
royal est riche montréal pullulent
d'investissement il ya des réalités il
ya des bulles par tout ce qu'on doit
faire cependant face à nous c'est de
s'assurer qu'on peut jouer pleinement
notre rôle pour créer l'environnement
qui est propice à l'investissement 90%
des sont donc des sondés de la chambre
de commerce du montréal métropolitain
disent par exemple organiser nous les
infrastructures assurez vous justement
qu'on peut savoir des permis rapidement
donné nous qu'on enlève la paperasse ça
c'est notre rôle ce mois comme maire
c'est mon rôle de m'assurer que je vois
je réponds en évitant je vais être un
catalyseur mais deuxièmement on a un
rôle à jouer également sur la scène
internationale faut envoyer un message à
air canada de dire que des vols directs
leur sa force car montréal aussi faut
amener des sièges sociaux davantage et
si on a besoin de quelqu'un qui est
capable de mettre le point sans état
d'âme je let le défenseur des
montréalais pour vrai
madame joly pour vraiment faire en sorte
d'améliorer l'environnement
d'investissement le climat d'affaires à
montréal dans les 100 premiers jours je
vais faire je m'assurerai que de donner
aux prises non jartazi on touche pas aux
taxes pour 80 et on va taper nos
infrastructures puis colas et le monde
des affaires si on a de la bonne gestion
pour tap les balles et les
infrastructures il va entendre 4
monsieur bergeron monsieur fillon il
faut bien comprendre qu à budget
constant si on baissait les taxes des
entreprises faudrait monter celle des
résidents de montréal mais on le ferry
on la regarde et on s'engage on le
faisait tous engagés à ne pas hausser
les taxes au delà de l'inflation si on
devait baisser celle des entreprises il
faudrait forcément août aussi celle des
résidents on doit faire plus que
l'inflation qui frôle damas dans cette
question d'équité on ne doit
pas
suffire ce qu'on doit faire là aussi
c'est de s'assurer que les grecs
puissent se parler entre elles puis d'en
développer d'autres donc le design et la
culture on est en est une on est une
ville ne mettra pas le culturel on est
une métropole numérique mais des fois
j'ai l'impression qu'ils se parlent pas
entre eux évidemment réduit il faut
qu'on trouve une façon sur le plan
politique pour s'assurer qu'on peut
jouer pleinement notre madame joly
j'aille concrètes
monsieur côté en a parlé l'industrie du
jeu vidéo la principale raison au delà
des crédits d'impôt aussi parce qu'on en
a des universités à montréal on est une
ville universitaire et c'est important
justement de retenir nos talents c'est
ce qu'on est limité d'un point de vue
municipal qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
mais nous on est arrivé avec un bureau
de promotion de montréal dans nos
universités pour garder nos diplômés
parfait je vous signale qu'on me donne
souvent des temps de parole va que je
sais d'égaliser là je fais pas des choix
je tiens à vous dire maxime bertrand
questions du public alors général pour
ce thème environnement d'affaires nous
avons voulu ce sont des éléments aller
n'avait rien que je voie réservée aux
autobus un autobus et qu'on a fait est
qu'il existe des verts beaucoup plus
qu'un peuple au nom de l'attrait
d'aménager la voie réservée vous
annoncer des choses sont en train de se
faire les formes et vous monsieur garage
été formés bien encore plusieurs bonnes
heures pendant qu'ils gagnent c'est
important quand on n'a pas les moyens
avoir un train moins ça c'est clair dans
mon esprit deuxièmement si on veut faire
un serbe et ça peut être bien long terme
mais moi j'aime montréal nord puis ça
fait sept ans que j'essaye de voir quand
est-ce que celui depuis neuf mois
complétés donc on a besoin les gens pour
la congestion c'est pas dans vingt ans
et immédiatement on a besoin de
solutions concrètes immédiatement donc
plus de voies réservées mais travaille
en collaboration avec l'édition aussi ce
qui élimine et les condroz s'arranger
pour que les travaux de voirie sur les
rues se fasse plus rapidement et qu'on
n'est pas tous ces chantiers là qu'on
peut remarquer à montréal où il ya des
cônes rouge la route la rue est ouverte
aux personnes qui travaillent comme je
le dis dans mes 100 premiers jours ce
que je vais faire c'est que justement
nous on a un grand projet de système
rapide par bus qui est au sein de la
ville de montréal donc pour les
irritants de pie-ix et donc au sein de
la ville de montréal et moi je vais
mandater la stm pour arriver avec un
plan de match d'intégration des 62
premiers kilomètres pour monde est déjà
dans ce type on arrive à 7 millions de
km et ses 7 millions qui a été
développée non seulement par des experts
en transport en commun montréalais mais
également internationaux total on arrive
dans le fond ainsi de façon générale
environ plus de 600 millions sont les
130 kg mais qui sont sur huit ans qu'on
a besoin de moi j'aime bien investi dans
peinture pour l'instant on va faire des
voies réservées comme comme comme mam
michèle le prolongement du métro c'est 5
points 5 km ça sera un milliard 1.2
milliard notre moi que je propose c'est
un milliard c'est québec finance non ça
serait montréal et il se serait en sport
on profiterait du vote du prochain
programme d'infrastructure canada on
sait coudre au québec va financer
l'électrification il va rester 5 à 600
millions à financer par les membres et
par le biais de services de la ville
pendant les 75 millions sur 2014 à 2017
moi je propose là qu'on fasse deux
projets 2014 début 2015 de serbie l'a1
entre le centre ville et l'aéroport 1 1
côte vertu et le métro sauvé pour
démontrer que ça fait coûte à peu près
25 30 millions $ payés à 100% par québec
un collectif voilà merci beaucoup c'est
là dessus qu'on s'arrête je vous
remercie très sincèrement
de vos interventions et d'avoir répondu
à plusieurs des questions ça c'est la
partie des bacs est terminé maintenant
on va donner la chance à chacun des
candidats de s'exprimer pendant une
minute pour les discours de clôture une
minute chacun on commence avec denis
coderre merci monsieur fillion dans un
premier temps on s'improvise peau mr
c'est pas un exercice de visibilité
c'est pas un exercice pour essayer
d'empêcher un candidat de se présenter
ou de faire un d'avoir un tremplin pour
l'avenir est maire de montréal c'est
quelqu'un qui a de l'expérience c'est
quelqu'un qui a une équipe c'est
quelqu'un qui va être en mesure
immédiatement de répondre au besoin on
mettre au point sa table tout le temps
mais quand on va être là on va se lever
avant tout pour les montréalais j'ai
cette expérience j'ai travaillé toute ma
vie avec la communauté avec la
population j'ai travaillé dans plusieurs
dossiers pour montréal et je veux mettre
à profit cet expert j'ai besoin de votre
support j'ai besoin de votre engagement
vous communauté d'affaires pour
améliorer le climat d'investissement
montréal mais également notre qualité
dit voter le 3 novembre pour du vrai
changement merci m jeudi une minute
maintenant à richard bergeron
merci monsieur fillion
la question la plus importante pour les
morellet l'enjeu le plus important
inclus en matière économique c'est celui
de s'assurer d'avoir une administration
intègre à partir du 4 novembre au matin
à la ville de montréal pour ça j'offre
l'équipe de projet montréal une équipe
parfaitement intègre qui existe depuis
dix ans le seul parti démocratique à
montréal une fois cette question de
l'intégrité assuré
je reprends le commentaire de mon
collègue denis coderre on ne s'improvise
pas maire de montréal on ne se présente
pas à la fin mai en za ça me tenterait
d'être maire de montréal le 4 novembre
prochain pour amalgamer al arabi est une
équipe en reprenant l'essentiel de ceux
qui nous ont fait entre ces dernières
années vous voyez le lien avec avec la
corruption dont je parlais plus tôt et
je terminerai en disant faut avoir de
l'ambition pour montréal il faut cesser
d'être pense petit hangar dans les
familles à montréal ce sont deux points
5 milliards de dollars d'investissements
qui deviennent disponibles sur l'île de
montréal et créent de la richesse à
montréal bergeron mais de financer des
projets pour les montréalais une minute
maintenant un marcel côté bonjour
l'économie de montréal tire de la patte
d depuis plusieurs années beaucoup de
stratégies ont été annoncés avec mise en
oeuvre avec les résultats qu'on connaît
l'économie tire toujours la patte 10% de
chômeurs l'industrie blick débat et
redis je sais que vous êtes nombreux à
participer continuer à commenter il ya
des commentateurs aussi tout de suite
après la pause avec anne marie dussault
pour analyser ce débat je vous rappelle
la date de l'élection c'est le 3
novembre prochain à aller voter c'est
important et notre prochain rendez vous
c'est rdi économie demain on va revenir
justement sur les enjeux économiques de
cette élection merci bonne soit